-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night."
How is everybody doing tonight
New York is back, you guys
It's beautiful out,
and the CDC just said
rats don't have to wear masks.
[ Laughter ]
So, we get to see their cute
little faces again.
Let's get to the news.
You guys, I'm not
a superstitious man.
All I'm saying is that Biden
took one picture
with Jimmy Carter,
and now there's a crisis
in the Middle East,
a gasoline shortage,
and low-rise jeans are back.
I don't want to
be disrespectful,
but he might be a leprechaun
"Let me get a picture with you
Jimmy.
Oh, you'll get the picture
all right!"
Take it down!
The Colonial Pipeline
restarted operations yesterday
five days after being shut dow
by a cyberattack,
which is good because we wer
reaching dangerous levels
of smugness in Tesla owners.
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy yesterday
pushed back against claims
that Republicans are still
focused on the 2020 election
and said, "I don't think anybody
is questioning the legitimac
of the presidential election."
Added McCarthy, "And I think
Vice President Biden
would agree with that."
That's right, Kevin McCarthy
said that
no one is questioning the
legitimacy of the 2020 election.
Then he said, "Oh,
that's my phone.
Who do I know in Florida?
Oh."
The New York Yankees
announced yesterday
that at least seven member
of the coaching staff
have tested positive
for the coronavirus
despite
all receiving the vaccine.
And that's weird because usually
when Yankees get injections,
they work.
Wally, did you get that one,
Wally? Did you get it?
-No.
-When asked the median price
for a home in Brooklyn,
former City Housing Commissioner
and New York mayoral candidate
Shaun Donovan
vastly underestimated the cost
and said that the average pric
of a home is $80,000 to $90,000,
which, in his defense,
is the average price of a home
for your car in Brooklyn.
According to a new study,
the coronavirus can stay
in men's genitals
for a long period of time
after recovery.
Said men, "Challenge accepted.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the United States
is experiencing
a chicken shortage
because roosters are not meeting
breeding expectations.
Said roosters,
"You told people?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Swedish furniture retailer IKE
announced yesterday
it will offer --
it will offer
a pulled-pork sandwich
in its restaurants,
if you have the patience
to put it together.
And that --
[ Laughs ]
A lot of --
Got a lot of farm humor tonight.